that was that little spit on you all
right my first line I want to say
ride-along
I think dammit it's that part of the
play Kevin getting old
that was so plain damn it all right a
little wet but I still look good
sings like a man god dammit what Oh
Raffi's i'ma stop you right there I
never said I was in in fact I expressly
remember saying that I was out since
your televisions superintelligence all
right that's one you know what they got
in Afghanistan landmines
boom you got no legs boom you got no
legs right along yeah look anybody call
in a fight with you right now
ain't nobody calling to fight with you
right now
think like a man all right check this
out you're throwing way too many big
words at me because I don't understand
them I'm gonna take that as disrespect
oh this is one of the ones that pop me
this is for the old virgin that's right
that's right you making me mad
[ __ ] you making me mad
[ __ ]
there's only two movies I said
[ __ ] in this is get hard yep
we were very scattered today this type
of thing almost never happens that's at
a Funeral liberated forever domesticated
never figure like for Pepsi hey I'm
sorry about your wife
this is either get hard for its thing
like it me I'm gonna go get hard get
hard I knew it I knew it wasn't I felt
that one did you see that I did the
thing did you see that I did the thing
Oh
Central Intelligence I did the thing is
this cuz you ate the cake that I do
what's love got to do with it cuz you
laid the cake about last night
only had three lives in that movie
that's why I didn't notice I'm not a
barbarian
he keeps clinching I can't make an
assertion what it keeps clenching
I can't make it all Oh Little Fockers
yes it was I was a nurse what you doing
in the truck
what are you doing in the trunk what you
doing in van trunk
seriously funny what a [ __ ] night
I see all these muscle cars but I don't
see no muscle that's right I'm on to ya
papa wrong that's not bad
all of us on the right this is Kevin
Hart